tout ce que nous défendons aujourd'hui
deviendrez lettre morte si nous avions
dans les prochaines semaines et les
prochains mois crédibiliser notre
capacité en européen avec nos
coopérations nos alliés nos alliances à
nous défendre aussi et à défendre en
particulier
notre flanc oriental une vision qui
n'est pas nouvelle soixante dix ans
avant emmanuel macron jean-monnet
envisageait déjà d'organiser la défense
de l'europe l'inspirateur de la
déclaration schuman rédigé à bazoches
sur guyonne veut aller plus loin qu'une
communauté du charbon et de l'acier le
commissaire au plan français imaginent
l'idée d'une armée européenne à l'été
1950 il présente son projet à rené
pleven président du conseil français en
plein contexte de guerre froide et de
guerre de corée les américains à un site
beaucoup les européens à
s'organiser pour
reconstituer une force militaire et donc
l'idée c'est ben de lancer cette
communauté européenne de défense c'est à
dire une armée européenne qui serait
placée sous commandement de l'otan mais
qui serait composé de deux forces
militaires qui vient proviendrait de
tous les pays qui sont membres de la
première communauté européenne donc les
six pays membres dont l'allemagne le 27
mai 1952 après des mois de négociations
le traité instituant la cod signé à
paris la communauté européenne de
défense regroupe aux côtés de la france
l'italie la belgique les pays bas le
luxembourg et l'allemagne de l'ouest de
table interactive rappelle cet épisode à
la maison jean monnet à bazoches sur
guyonne les pays membres mettent en
commun
des soldats des forces militaires qui
sont placés sous le commandement d'une
haute autorité indépendante elle même
sous commandement de l'otan et donc on a
finalement une arme et un peu de cette
un mode fédéral si vous voulez 1,40
division de 13 mille soldats sous
uniforme commun sont évoqués mais le
projet soulève des débats houleux en
france voir l'allemagne réarmer quelques
années après la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale suscite de nombreuses craintes
gaullistes et communistes s'unissent
contre le traité qui est rejeté le 30
août 1954 par l'assemblée nationale la
communauté européenne de défense est
déjà mise en échec ça va même provoqué
la démission de jean monnet qui était le
président de la haute autorité du
charbon et de l'acier à luxembourg qui
décident de finalement jeter l'épongé
la construction européenne s'orientera
finalement sur les questions de commerce
et de nucléaire civil le thème de la
défense ne sera que très peu évoqué
jusqu'à la création en 2004 de l' agence
européenne de la défense l'idée d'une
défense européenne commune elle est
reçue rhji cette année avec le début de
la guerre en ukraine